what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
today welcome to morning coffee thoughts
except I'm not drinking coffee I'm still
coffee free for everyone that's been
following along my journey this is tea
I've been doing better A lot of people
were asking me why
they're like coffee can be good for you
why don't you just keep drinking coffee
black coffee has all these health
benefits I'm like guys if I could drink
coffee in a healthy way I would drink
coffee
but
I like sugar coffee I like coffee like
this much coffee a lot of creamer I like
milkshakes for breakfast basically
um so I was just thinking if I can't
drink it healthy and I don't like it
healthy I might as well just not drink
it at all this is just how I think
So today we're talking about
Andrew Tate video
so as you guys know
um
I did the video with Andrew Tate
um
I'm gonna tell you guys how it all came
about and the challenges that now we've
we've come about so this video was so
hard to put together basically I was
supposed to go to Dubai and film it in
Dubai and this actually Brittany Renner
did not want to go to Dubai so it's a
good thing that we actually ended up
doing in London because she wouldn't
have ended up being able to go
um so we're gonna go to Dubai and do a
panel there and I bought tickets I
bought hotels that I can't
I can't even pay back which so I spent a
lot of money
um that I can't get back it was
non-refundable which is a lesson I
learned to always make everything do the
trip insurance and stuff lessons lesson
learned just a lesson
um so
basically I found out last minute like a
day or two out before I was supposed to
fly my manager went to Dubai and he had
an emergency passport they don't accept
those there I couldn't get into Dubai
either because my passport expires
within six months so I'm like last
minute trying to get a passport I go to
the Embassy can't go I have to cancel
all the flights tell everyone not to
come blah blah blah
so then
um Tate agrees to come to us and
he flies
um we pick out a date so then I have to
like replan everything and I decided to
cancel shows or we tried to recruit for
shows but it was like
everything was just so chaotic
um got Brittany Renner to agree to come
um got two other girls to be on the
panel we got everything ready and yeah
we did the panel and it was a lot of fun
I actually got along with Brittany
better than I thought I would because I
just thought we'd disagree on more but
she's actually more based
um than I thought she was going to be
now a couple I'm going to say a couple
complaints that I've gotten from people
they say she's manipulating me
guys look it she might be I don't know
but my thing is if someone's nice to me
why would I not be nice back
um
they they said you're letting Britney do
a whole apology tour look it okay guys
let's take that premise let's say
Brittany that's what she's trying to do
she's trying to grift Rebrand all of
that stuff let's just let's just go to
the extreme anyone who takes her
seriously that says more about the
interviewer blah blah blah guys I'm
thinking about the next generation of
women
if if she has had mistakes that she
regrets now even if it's a fake regret
to be a whole apology to her rebrandt
all the stuff you guys said why why not
let her be public and let the people see
and they can make the decision for
themselves why not let the next
generation of women know this is what
city girl culture becomes like the and
it could be fake it could not be genuine
I don't know you know
um
it seemed
genuine to me but again I don't know so
that's that's number one Brittany Renner
okay
um two
YouTube has now
so I dropped the panel with Andrew Tate
on
Christmas so today is the 26th I dropped
it on Christmas
it got a million views in a day which is
literally amazing
um and then YouTube decided to age
restrict my video meaning that they
everyone has to be signed in to watch it
which I don't think the majority of
people are signed in
um and it has to say that they're above
18 on their account so now the Matrix
The Matrix is
is coming for
my chat I would say more it's because
Andrew Tate's in the video but
it's just
um
a bit crazy that
you put all this work into a video just
for them to age restrict it but you know
um we're gonna be posting a lot of Clips
so you know what else can you do and
we're gonna post it on Rumble too so
um
so you know what can you do you just
roll with the punches but if you guys
have any interesting ideas for like
collabs
um I think I'm gonna do more with Tate
and I just think there's some
interesting things we could do
um
I think
yeah let me know in the comments the
the and same with Brittany if there's
any anything you guys or other
influencers you know the next thing I
want to talk to you guys about so I'm
just being honest here
I have been doing four streams a week
for
sense
June or July
I started my show February 27th I did it
three days a week back then I did
everything myself and slowly hired
things out
um upped it to four days a week in like
June or July
um
and I just want to be honest I'm getting
a little bit bored of the studio model
where I just debate people every week
and it's like kind of the same thing
that's why I opened um I started the
channel live school which I am going
through everyone's like everyone is so
um quick to jump they're like well
you're not a wife well you're a modern
woman you're not prioritizing finding a
husband I'm like guys I'm so smart I
figured out a way to make my job getting
better for my husband
like to find a house anyways
again I'm smart now anyways this is my
point
I
don't see us staying four days a week in
the future I I could see in the future
going down to two
um and maybe increasing the number of
Street interviews or something else
um it's not to say that I won't ever go
up to four but
um just the last year the show has
started at nine and it's just so late
that I kind of want to see if we can
start it earlier and I really want to
just like get a normal sleep schedule
again
um so it's either I'm gonna do it last
days of the week so it's only one to two
days I'm staying up crazy late or
um I'm gonna move the show earlier
um
so I don't know what I'm gonna do yet um
I'd like to film more wife school I
might take January
I'm sorry I'm getting
um I might take January off from shows
um and just do
and just do like interviews and like I
also really wanted to bring a lot of the
conversations that we have on the
couches and not in the studio to the
streets so I really wanted to take so
like for example I wanted to interview
the beautiful majestic creatures about
why their weight is so out of control
you know and it's not to like humble
them or whatever or like you know
interview women over the age of 50 55 on
or do they are any of them really happy
not having kids and these are the
questions that like I I would like to
take the things that we talk about and
see if I can go interview them in real
life
um and then you go you know I was
thinking maybe I would do like a show
season an interview season where I'm
doing both but I'm just so creative I
can't do like the same piece type of
content all the time and I've just felt
myself getting a bit like
burnt out the last couple months and I
it's really important to me that I'm
bringing the quality of you know the
shoots up but these are just ideas I'm
thrown off you but
yeah I I think it's crazy that YouTube
suppresses
people that they disagree with or people
that tell the truth about uncomfortable
things
um and I'm actually quite nervous that
they might at some point do that to me
so I don't know guys subscribe to my
Rumble um it's usually in the
description of my live shows um
Twitter Instagram it's
it's tough because
you have so many people that rely
like you know there's I think 13 people
that work at just early things so it's
like
those people get out of a job if they
take away the channel
um and it's just you know I think Tate
was in a position where it doesn't
really affect him money-wise but it's
like
you know they take people's livelihoods
when they do that so it's wrong I don't
know but let me know in the comments
what you guys think
um sorry I'm a bit all over the place
today I'm a little sick but subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
Bell I'll talk to you next time